SPEAKER_00: At T plus 0.678 seconds, the first warning appeared.
SPEAKER_00: It was smoke from the aft field joint of Challenger's right solid rocket booster.
SPEAKER_00: More smoke followed through the first two and a half seconds of flight.
SPEAKER_00: Then it stopped.
SPEAKER_00: For the next minute, Challenger looked like a launch.
SPEAKER_00: The vehicle climbed.
SPEAKER_00: The callouts continued.
SPEAKER_00: The machinery of the mission appeared to be doing what it had done before.
SPEAKER_00: But the accident had already begun.
SPEAKER_00: The visible catastrophe came later, about 73 seconds after liftoff.
SPEAKER_00: By then, the public version could be told quickly.
SPEAKER_00: It was cold, the O-rings failed, and seven crew members died.
SPEAKER_00: That version is accurate.
SPEAKER_00: It is also too small to explain why launch was still allowed.
SPEAKER_00: The smoke is the better starting point because it separates the consequence from the beginning.
SPEAKER_00: At 73 seconds, the chain became public.
SPEAKER_00: At less than one second, the chain became physical.
SPEAKER_00: Before that, the chain had already been organizational.
SPEAKER_00: The harder question starts before ignition.
SPEAKER_00: How does a warning stay visible in records, inspections, memos, charts, and meetings, then arrive at the final decision two weeks to stop the machine?
SPEAKER_00: Challenger did not fail because the danger was invisible.
SPEAKER_00: It failed after a system learned how to keep flying with evidence that should have made flying harder.
SPEAKER_00: To understand how that happens, start with the promise the shuttle system had to keep.
SPEAKER_00: Mercury, Gemini and Apollo were built around singular missions, dedicated hardware, dedicated risk, dedicated public attention.
SPEAKER_00: The shuttle was designed to break that model.
SPEAKER_00: Reusable, frequent, routine, less expedition, more airline.
SPEAKER_00: That promise shaped the organization around it.
SPEAKER_00: When a program promises routine, every delay starts to mean something different.
SPEAKER_00: A scrub is still an engineering decision, but it is also a schedule problem, a budget problem, a public problem, a problem that moves through contracts, payload windows, congressional expectations, and the reputation of the agency.
SPEAKER_00: NASA entered 1986 with an aggressive flight schedule and a system that had to justify itself through repetition.
SPEAKER_00: The shuttle was not only a spacecraft, it was an operating model.
SPEAKER_00: The first thing to understand about Challenger is that the program was built to make spaceflight feel normal.